as chair of the house of ways and means
committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the corporate 19 pandemic
in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020.04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a work session on two house
bills house bill 10
house bill 15 and also
an executive session when these bills
may be held
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporarily to this meeting however
according to the emergency order i am
confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaries
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaries listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available on the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
and the notice for this meeting complies
with the house rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
hcs like dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled i want to introduce the
staff that are on the meeting
to assist us jennifer four and committee
researcher
or the committee researcher please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call of
attendance when each member states their
presence please
also state whether there is anyone in
the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
representative bernstein please take the
role
thank you mr chair and good morning to
you and good morning to everyone
it's march the 3rd 2021
9 a.m it's a beautiful day in the
granite state let's begin roll call with
representative patrick abrami here in my
home in stratham
accepting the award for mary griffin is
representative jeanine notter
i'm at my home in merrimack and it's
just uh me and my dog right now
representative sir uh present home
hudson wife is in the house someplace
representative russ
ober representative ober
representative representative doucette
good morning i'm on my uh mobile device
in concord
good morning your humble clerk is alan
burstein and i'm here in my home office
in nottingham new hampshire
representative robert elliott uh here
in my uh home and my wife uh
in salem is somewhere in the house thank
you
representative jeanine yes i'm here i'm
home in salem and my wife is somewhere
in the house
representative herschel nunes good
morning
representative bursting thank you i am
home alone in pelham
representative tim baxter thank you
representative i'm home alone
representative terry spillsbury good
morning home alone in charlestown
representative paul tudor
i'm home in northwood my wife is in the
house representative susan army
home alone in lebanon representative
richard ames
i'm here in jeffrey in my home office
representative thomas southwood here in
dover
alone good morning representative dennis
malloy
home in uh greenland alone you look
sharp this morning representative
thank you representative schamberg uh
i'm alone and i'm in the new london
hospital parking lot
sorry uh i'm home alone in randolph
thank you for the weather report
representative jeannie gamarlo
jenny gamarlo what did you say
i am holmen swansea alone representative
thomas laughman
representative laughman representative
amanda gourd
good morning i am present and alone
representative mary hacken phillips good
morning
i'm coming to you live from my office in
concord alone
representative james murphy good morning
i'm in hanover at my uh
home office alone and repre and
chairman norman major good morning
i'm in my office in my home and my wife
is in the house
mr chair there are 22 members present
two are absent
this morning we are going to
deal with two bills left over from
yesterday
house bill 10 and house bill 15.
with our leadership because
house bill 10 also deals with
reduction in business taxes both the bpt
and bet
and that the governor's budget has the
bt
reduction in it halfway
that is recommended that
we retain this bill doesn't mean you
the way our leadership feels um
so representative romney do you have a
motion i make a motion to retain
house bill 10. representative romney
makes a motion
to retain house bill 10 which is an act
relative to the rates of business
profits tax and business enterprise tax
and i had such a nice blurb already
i save it
representative anything you want to say
on that
i think it's prudent of us to to wait
and see what happens with the budget
and the uh the various tax cuts that are
in the budget
and we can hold this in abeyance and
and pull it out if we need it later on
any other questions or comments on house
bill 10
if not then i'll ask the clerk to call
the vote
on house bill 10 and the motion is to
retain
thank you mr chair um let's begin the
roll call vote
on hb 10 with representative abrami
yes representative notter
yes representative
urry
you mean my cursor over there
yes representative ober
is not present the clerk votes yes
didn't yes oh thank you representative
elliot
representative tim baxter yes
from northwood representative paul tudor
yes
representative susan allmey yes
yes thank you representative tom
southworth
yes representative dennis malloy
yes representative thomas schamberg
yes representative edith tucker
yes representative jenny gomarlo
yes representative tom laughman
yes good morning representative amanda
yes representative mary hacken phillips
yes representative james murphy
yes
mr chair of the vote to retain hb 10
23 to nothing with one member not voting
vote been 23 or nothing to retain the
bill
the motion passes thank you
we have a good morning this morning
is house bill i mean
another question representative
baxter were you able to
get that amendment thank you mr chair
um so as i communicated with you
yesterday
i talked to the dra and
we agreed upon language and essentially
what we did
is my amendment originally talked about
the
provider so um travel safe
service agents but this amendment makes
it cleaner and it just
changes it to looking at um the charge
that way you can't basically be wholly
exempt if
part of your business is a travel
service
um agent agency so that was the change
they recommended and i thought
their proposed language was fine so the
only hang up right now
is it's already been submitted to oos
they just
need to review it um so i would
recommend
that we wait until we get it back from
os
and next week we can vote on the
amendment
and then pass the bill that way
hopefully this can end up on consent
and it won't take up any time on the
floor
oh and mr chair real quick i ccg on that
last email
the last two emails to ols so you'll
when did you do that uh
one was yesterday afternoon towards the
end of the day after we had the
we agreed upon the proposed language and
then this morning as well
and one yesterday i forwarded it to
um
representative
sorry the one the one you forwarded to
us on i
was not entirely sure which language
from that long
email was supposed to be being
considered
and which wasn't can we maybe at least
get a a clean copy of that
perhaps representative baxter could send
what he
what he sent to ols to all of us right
now or put it up on the screen or
something
yeah i i should be able to do that right
now for your representative
thank you
mr chair yes so i've got the email up
but how do i
share it a screen share hold on
your name um
i think i'm getting it right now yeah
okay
can you guys see yep yes
you might make it big you see it there
too
one of the uh lucky parts about being
young is i have good eyesight
for now maybe because now the whole
thing isn't showing
okay let's i'll say one i think it
should
or just scroll down a little bit yeah
there you go
so it's just from right here where my
cursor is right
so what was added was what
what isn't hello yes exactly
and essentially what what the what they
were doing
is my original amendment was talking
about the occupation travel service
agents
but there was the issue that that might
wholly exempt
someone that a small part of their
business is them being a travel service
agent which would not was not what was
intended
so this changes it to the
looking at the charges so amounts
paid by an operator to a travel agent or
commission
and then exempt that the term rent shall
not include amounts paid by an operator
to a travel agent as commissioner
compensation
for travel agent services so looking at
the actual
so what has been sent over to the
yeah this is this is from os the email
sent to all of us
itself so this is this is how the
amendment
but i imagine we can meet um
back next week i don't know when all of
us will we'll
send something over it could even be
tomorrow if we could all meet tomorrow
but it
it shouldn't take uh that long once
once we have something back from all of
us
we haven't been noted to meet tomorrow
but we will be meeting oh my god okay
which is a week from today
because next tuesday is election day
everybody
so this could be taken up
on election day is everybody agreeable
to this
senator mr chair um
if i may go forward um yeah
the uh this looks good to me on the face
of it
uh but uh it looks like we'll have a
little time to look closely at it so i
think
the the plan would be to go
into executive session presumably maybe
a
little prior discussion when we next
meet which would be wednesday next week
um and uh and then unless some
wrinkle is identified we're off and
running
that's the way i would understand it we
don't have the actual amendment in front
of us
yet and so we should process it
something like that
and i think we've got plenty of time uh
since we don't have a scheduled
so mr mr chairman representative
you have uh representative nunes and
representative spillsbury wanting to
talk and it might be better if they do
it today rather than
wait till to wednesday but i think the
chair was going to respond to what i
just said
come next wednesday
i think we need to take a vote and
examine
whether the amendment is not ready or
not
we should be able to execute because it
can always have a forum and then
the floor amendment could have the
support of
the whole committee in our particular
both but i think we need to move this
thing out
but as far as discussion we're open to
discussion right now
so um
uh did you call on me mr chairman yes
um i just thank you mr chairman i have i
have a question for representative
baxter
in your conversation with um with drs
did
did did you guys work out the way that
they would be looking at the rules
uh that would be created going towards
the rules committee i'm taking it
i want to take it for granted this is
going to fix that but i want to hear it
from
you guys that this is going to uh ease
ease up the conflict that she was
talking about
the assistant commissioner was talking
about before
um making the rules off of off the
statute
yeah thank you representative i think we
this process basically she put in an
amendment that she'd be comfortable with
that would have
um what she was saying she felt that
could be accomplished in
rules so i think it's sort of just
ironing out
some of those details ahead of time
instead of doing it in the rules process
that's basically how i took it i looked
over the language she sent back
and i actually thought it was it was a
better approach than my amendment
originally and it ironed out the
concerns
that she had and that other members had
so
i i think it's just it's much simpler
and easier and in terms of whether we
exact this today or we wait till the
10th
a big thing that's going on is just our
time on the floor
and if we can get this out um unanimous
or maybe there might be one person or
something like that that doesn't vote
for
it could go on consent and that's going
to save us a lot of time versus if we
have to have a floor amendment
if it's not unanimous if we have to
debate this or whatever on the floor
i would rather just wait to the 10th
take five minutes
and exec it out and have it be on
consent
so that's just my suggestion for um for
the chair
and i'm happy to hear what other members
of the committee think about that as
well
and thank you representative for your
question thank you for the answer
yes sir mr chair i'm great thank you
okay representative spillsberg
thank you mr chairman um i appreciate
what uh representative basker but facts
are
trying to do and i do think that this
approach
is better than uh than the one we were
looking at yesterday
so my fear was that uh
amending the definition of operator was
going to largely gut the intent of the
bill so now we're
we are proposing to amend the
definitions
of
gross rental receipts and
elaborate on full retail price charge
take gross rental receipts
what this then does is lists three
things and now a fourth
that um are not to be included
in a gross rate of receipt and those are
things like
separate charges for insurance
or for fuel that's very logical
i think this amendment though invites
the operators
to begin stating
um booking commissions
as a separate charge to remove them from
their meals and rooms rather than to
leave them in
and as far as you know i can see the
normal business practice is
that a room operator
car rental operator grosses up their
charges determines their profit level
decides what they're going to charge the
customer
and then pays their expenses including
booking commissions so
i'm still not totally comfortable with
this and i
guess where i would go with with my
doubt
is back to carolyn lear's note
where she says we think that the bill is
reasonably clear as it is
and gives us the uh power
uh in the rule-making authority to
clarify things now in a rule-making
authority they can be much more granular
specific take testimony and
take comments on a proposed rule
and i don't think we're in a position
here to deal with it as carefully as
they would
so i think there are ambiguities that
remain um
and so again you know with the full
respect for
what representative baxter is attempting
to do
i think we could probably better leave
um
representing early
what is the uh our time schedule on this
bill uh
mr chair can we wait until the 10th or
later
the 11th is the last day to report all
house bills
in the second committee except the
budget bills
so that the 10th
and you have one day after that
so we either voted up or down on the uh
with amendment or without an amendment
on the 10th other than that we're going
to have to screw around with it on the
floor if anyone has any objections
i just wanted that to be clear to the
members okay
the other thing is sir in the past the
committee has done things
uh pending uh
ols approval do we want to consider that
now or do you think we have plenty of
time on the
10th to mesh this out
i was going to throw that out but i
thought i'd wait to hear from everybody
that's an option but i don't know how
mr chair just to follow up uh to help
everybody and to
to help uh representative baxter
uh would it be appropriate that we get a
a sense of the committee uh at this
point so that he knows
um what uh
how we feel basically
yes we can do that um but why don't we
wait until
everybody makes their comments and
uh thank you mr chair it seemed to me
before
your plan about um
completing this bill on the 10th after
we probably will have the amendment
seemed fine
now it seems like we're looking at other
options but
it seemed like your original comments
about that were going to work fine
and on the 10th we can go up or down on
the amendment and then up or down on the
bill
and we're done that's that's the
committee's choice
so i support that suggestion from you
all right thank you for representing all
of me
thank you on
if i can remember now what i was trying
to when i put my hand up before
uh this um
i think that it would be useful if we
could get
on on miss lear to get
on on uh into this conversation right
now
to to talk to us about the the
uh problem that might be caused by
putting that
uh first part of the amendment in the
second part of the amendment doesn't
look like
its problem the first one is in a place
where everything else has been
uh put on the receipt um
i think that it since she agreed to it
before she'd be okay but it
would be helpful i think if we had that
resolved
now so that we don't if we try to go
back with an amendment on the 10th
they're probably going to be a lot of
committees doing that
right then janine can you
let
uh
[Music]
hi representatives carolyn lear
assistant commissioner at the department
of revenue here
i've been listening discussion um
but i think it would be helpful to uh if
representative almi could repeat this
specific
question that she was wishing for me to
answer
yes i was trying to get the the language
back
up i took a screenshot of it
mr chair i just wanted to update you
real quickly i just got an email
um from jeff from ols and he said he's
gonna send it out as soon as possible so
we might get that
okay susan have you
uh i'm sorry
i don't seem to be able to both look at
the language and
unmute myself um
can
here i think i'm doing a work around now
but a share on the screen would be nice
um maybe representative baxter can put
thank you so on the second
yellow part seems like
it doesn't have any problem at all the
question is whether
it's a problem that uh the first yellow
part
d uh amounts paid by an operator to a
travel agent as commissioner
compensation
is out of sync with the rest of that
section
which is separate charges
um i tend to agree with you
that a through c very clearly
charges that are paid by the consumer
and section d is explicitly dealing with
that are paid by the operator to a
travel agent
as commission um
i don't know from a drafting standpoint
whether
um that will be seen as a fatal issue
hopefully um ols will will weigh in on
that
um it just seemed as though the only
logical place
um if you do um add that language to do
so
would it be possible
to just stick i don't know what it would
be uh romans 6
a uh or something like that
to just stick in at the bottom amounts
paid by an operator to travel agents
commissioner compensation for the
travel agents services on
shall not be considered part
i'm sorry representative i'm not sure
that i followed
my brain must be working a little slow
this morning yeah well mine is not too
happy
either so on
there to have a second section under
roman
6 that just says amounts paid by an
operator to a travel agent as
commissioner compensation for the travel
agent
services on are not part of gross rental
receipts
from my perspective that wouldn't change
the meaning
um so that would be fine i would defer
to
ols on preferred from a drafting
standpoint
perhaps representative baxter could
representative ahmee can you just repeat
the the question that you wanted me to
address specifically
um under roman six
uh you've got gross receipts means and
the term shall not
include a through c and then
on somehow after romans 6
romans 6 a or whatever it is that they
could do
amounts paid by an operator to a travel
agent
on show on on
on is not considered as part of
gross rental receipts or some such
wording
okay so to clarify you just want it in a
slightly different
spot um hopefully that will provide some
clarity that's kind of what you're
you're like oh i was trying to to
address i think it's representative
spellberg's points
point that it is is
not part of the charges paid by the
consumer
it would be a separate section roman
mr chairs if i can i just want to speak
to you real quick representative
spillsberry's
um his uh concerns and it was it was my
understanding that
the way this was written um by carolyn
the dra felt comfortable
through the rule-making process that
this would have
the outcome that was intended um and so
i would just
want to ask to her again if you know if
she still feels comfortable with this
amendment
that it's not going to lead to any
unforeseen outcomes
like the ones spillsbury is potentially
yes representative baxter with this
language
i feel comfortable that either
rules won't be necessary or if we do
determine that rules
are necessary that we'll be able to um
clearly enact what the committee is
intending
thank you i agree with that too it's
if i can jump in again yes
thank you mr chairman uh
the incongruity is this
roman numeral six is a definition of
gross rental
receipts gross rental seats are amounts
paid by the customer to the operator
but little d which has been added has
nothing to do with
gross rental receipts it's simply
a statement i believe that a particular
expense
is not going to be taxed twice
clearly an amount paid by the
customer to the operator is subject to
the tax
and if we're trying to say anything here
it's that
when the operator then goes and pays the
commission it's not taxed a second time
uh it really doesn't fit in a definition
of gross rental receipts
i'm representing spillsberry a lot of
things that we do
writing tax law are
cya in nature that is our belts and
suspender is the
more um acceptable term i underst
i suppose that is yeah it may not belong
there
but we're saying it anyway so that you
get the message
uh it's kind of uh yeah your belt holds
your pants up
and so do use your suspenders you don't
need both
but a lot of people do and this
we do and i think that's what section d
is
it's a belts and suspenders approach so
that
if if a jail car ever gets a chance to
look at this
they'll look at it and say well they
mean that
commission doesn't count because they
said it here
and they said it here and they set it
everywhere so
that's kind of what it is yeah it may
not exactly
fit where it is but it does clarify
because it doesn't fit i that that's my
take on this
thank you very briefly um i take your
point but i think this one is not so
much
an example of what you're saying i think
this is going to be red to give the
wrong message and it's going to
it's going to basically say go ahead and
list this
charge separately and you'll be fine and
it'll be exempt from tax
and the gross amount that the customer
pays
you know what's subject to tax anyway
and i think i've made my point i don't
want to
you're muted yeah got it
um i guess there's maybe
asking the question that we're exploring
in a different way but i just want to
whether there is any danger that
a travel agent working with an operator
could have essentially gained this
system
and effectively
reduce the rent that's subject to the
tax
and raise the travel agent
compensation number
good question thank you for the
question representative um it sounds
like you all
um saw the email that i sent to
representative baxter yesterday
and before i i suggested
the language that you have before you i
did try to reiterate the point
that i do think it's clear under the
statute
um without any additional language that
amounts paid um but the the
tax only captures amounts paid by the
consumer
um and doesn't um capture in the tax
base
amounts paid um between
the operator and any service provider
um because it's a tax on a consumer
transaction
i only say that because i think of
course
inherent in adding any language is
the risk that someone will find a way
to um utilize it to
um potentially exempt a transaction
that they that we don't intend to be
exempt i think that's always a risk and
certainly could be a risk
with this language as well i mean i've
certainly because that's
my job as the tax administrator to um
try to propose something that i thought
was uh as
tight as it could be um
but my answer would be that that is
thank you represented southwark
you muted i know i it wasn't it's not
the muting that's my finger like most
people
um i just wanted to clarify
um with a miss lear going back to the
original bill
um at that point you felt it was fine
without an amendment and you thought
rules could handle it
and i just want to make sure from your
perspective
that that choice is still on the table
to just pass the bill
thank you for the question
representative um
yes i agree with that statement um i
i don't think that um
an amendment is necessary to achieve
or clarify um what this amendment
seeks to clarify i think that
the statute does make clear
that commissions paid by the operator to
a travel agent
are is not taxable and i do think it's
clear enough
that i would be comfortable saying that
we have the authority to enact rules
to such effect thank you
thank you i wanted to address on
something i think it was representative
hollery said
i do not think that a lot of travel
agents
would want to have their commission
on on
public documents that the that the
uh customer sees i've never seen them
do that kind of thing the commissions
are always kind of hidden in the
background
on if we had to do something like this
could we maybe change d to any amounts
paid uh that appear
as a charge which
does anybody else have any comments or
questions
and i think we've got
to address an issue here
is what we've heard from the
commissioner is that
she feels comfortable with the
[Music]
bill as is and that
any issue with it can be taken care of
through the rules
and then we also have the other thing
that
you know we need to have an amendment
so i'd like to find out from the
committee how the
members of the committee feel should we
go the route of no amendment
or the right amendment
and uh this is not
it's an indication how the members feel
and then you can vote twice if you want
who would vote for this
without an amendment
could we raise our hands yes virtually
or
let's do it this way if you are
against putting this
in without an amendment has ought to
pass
raise your hand say it again norm say it
putting this in as ought to pass without
an amendment
raise your hand in other words for the
amendment
no no no the opposite no
yeah i don't know we've got to be clear
if you're far less without an amendment
if yeah
[Music]
eight nine ten eleven
okay if you are one
to see this bill pass with an amendment
one two three four five
okay okay
four five honestly if you just use the
raised
maybe we should use that function i
agree
right at the top of where the panelists
are okay
use the raised hands function
if you want this bill to pass
with an amendment use your raised hand
function
with the amendment so the way you're
saying and we aren't allowed to vote
twice
okay raise hand function if you want the
amendment
i said one two three four five
i thought there was more hands than that
that's six
is six okay if you do not want to see an
amendment
[Music]
it's it's almost like a 2-1
mr chairman could you ask if on
the people who want an amendment
would be willing to go to the floor for
that
do we have because you have been trying
all right if it went to the floor
mr chairman representative schamberg
here
representative schamberg what yes uh
i remember correctly back on february
10th i was the only one that opposed the
bill
in committee and i
will oppose the bill no matter how it's
presented
and i will would like to do a minority
report
and i will speak on the floor
so
if we vote on the amendment i'm going to
vote against the amendment
but if the if the body wants the
amendment
i will vote yes on the bill with the
amendment i mean
doesn't mean i'm not going to vote for
the amendment uh
when we do the otp with amendment i will
vote for the bill with the amendment
um but after hearing all of what we just
heard
i'm still not convinced that the
amendment is needed
but again i will vote for the bill with
the amendment if that's what we
wind up if the the amendment does pass
then i will i'll vote against that but
then i will vote for the bill with the
amendment
all right chair may i add this is dennis
malloy
um most of the people on who sponsored
the bill are in this room
or in this chat are in this in a zoom
with the exception of speaker
packard and uh
i think we have we can dispense we can
decide this now with the folks that are
who are
sponsors of the bill
how many would like to take the vote
now use your
mr chairman i'd like to say something
too if i could
yes mrs representative nunez
i believe i want to get back to the root
of this this amendment came up because
the dra was having problems with some of
the language
so an amendment came out and it and it
didn't quite
hit it but we went back and worked with
the dra and they said that
this would help them in their making
their rules and that it would clarify
things for them
she also just said to us just a few
minutes ago that she didn't know
if that last line that we were looking
at in there on that d line or whatever
it was
was going to cause come out of ols
differently than what it's expected
until we see the actual amendment
come out of ols and know the way that
it's been legally worded by
the legal team in there then then i
think we're
sort of voting on something right now
that we're not seeing the true amendment
yet we're just seeing
the words that were sent as we all know
ols
changes things sometimes when it gets
there so until we see the amendment can
we not
vote on this until we see the actual
amendment
mr chairman on everybody's got their
hands up for a kind of
straw vote at this point and we can't
tell who wants
i forgot what the the question was in
this
alaska vote mr chairman the question
the question was can we not do this
until we see the actual amendment
that's my question because as was stated
earlier
when it's got to go to ols and we need
to make sure that it comes out of ols
with the intention
provided and we don't know that that's
what's going to happen because of one
line that's in there although the
assistant commissioner
did state to us just a few minutes ago
that she wanted to look at that line as
well to make sure that it comes out
correctly
until we have that language that's back
from them in an actual amendment then
i my suggestion is let's wait for the
amendment
mr chairman no wait i want to have
carolyn explain something again
carolyn without the amendment do
do we need the amendment to accomplish
carolyn representative major thank you
for the question
uh i'll i'll answer while refl
rephrasing it slightly
i don't believe that you need the
amendment
in order to ensure that the fees
paid to travel agents by
operators as commissions are not
subject to the tax i think it is clear
as the legislation is drafted without an
amendment
that those fees are not subject to tax
thank you i'm going to hold this until
the 10th
and i also um personally
i agree with the commissioner
but i'm holding this until the 10th
you'll
have an opportunity to look at the
amendment and we will vote on it
i had emailed you the information i
received from the
finance committee relative to the
sections
on house bill 2 that we need to look at
now when i looked at on the internet
house bill 2 was up on the internet
and uh but it's like a lot of pages
170 pages or so
and you can either do one of two things
either
get a copy over it at the lme
or try to work with it
on the internet or just download those
specific pages but
not only looking at those sections that
they
told us about what i would do
as a minimum i would go to the houseboat
too
and download and print the first
six pages the first six pages
is the analysis because there may be
other sections there that weren't
identified
because don't really want to be
surprised
the last minute there were some sections
that weren't identified by finance
that we need to do a
quick analysis on i'd rather analyze
these things right now rather than wait
to the last minute
so there's a lot of homework to do
any questions or comments for anything
there's a couple hands up okay yeah
representative skelsberg thank you mr
chairman
i may be confused this is a new topic
but i've lost track of what happened to
house bill 565 this is representative
ames bill
to establish a committee to study
charitable gaming
uh the notes that i made indicate that
we
approved otp 24-0
and agreed to put it on consent calendar
but looking at the consent calendar
uh in the house record february 19th
that we acted on last week in session
i don't see that 565 was on there
and have i lost track of it or did it
somehow administratively get overlooked
no it did not get overlooked it didn't
get to the
schedule in time to get on that calendar
so it will be on the new the next
calendar
and thank you thank you there's a 24-0
vote
about to pass
yep anything else
no i'm spat yes pat uh is there any way
jennifer can help us with the hp2
extracting of ways and means portion of
it
general four yeah i'll talk to her
there's a lot of things
and the easiest way is
is to go to the analysis and stop there
but make sure you cover all the points
that the finance committee
sent to us and then we'll also take care
of those other five bills
those other five bills that were second
committee bills
you look at them we will not touch the
policy we're not going to debate the
policy that's been passed by the house
we're only going to to look at those
parts that have to do
there may be a bill 10 pages and nine
and a half pages
is policy so you have to find where it
is
and i plan to go through it and i'll
send you out an
email which i think
and that's for we need to vote on that
they need to be reported out on their
weapons
okay mr chairman yes
on two things i think that we have
until we have until the 18th
that's that's in the the deadlines
in the calendar yes and right we have
18 second committee bills right yes
and the second uh thing is that at least
one of those bills we have because
on they took the fees out of it in the
committee but
they left in the uh dedicated
fund the rating of the dedicated funds
in order to pay for the database that
they want
and that rating was supposed to be
recompensed by the fees
that they took out so the question that
we're looking at
is what do we think of of the
stability of those dedicated funds
and the rules have dedicated funds in
and the rest of the rest of that bill
episode of elliot has his hand raised
represented elliot yes there's been so
much confusion over
this bill that i see no problem with
both parties having a caucus on how they
feel about this and i suggest that we
hold off
i like the idea of postponing it to the
10th
but i would prefer to have a republican
caucus and the democrats can have one
too
to exactly what it is we're voting on
because there's so much confusion on
this amendment
and the bill obviously that i think we
need to spend a little bit more time on
it
privately as the republicans and as
democrats thank you thank you
representative
and i would encourage you all
to keep your eyes out for anything
that's going to change the economic
conditions
that would result in our
revenues going one way to the other
and also this new stimulus package
once it's passed we need to understand
we get out of here early today